alors dites moi qu'est ce que vous
ressentez je vois des symboles partout
des signes bizarres déjà mon prénom
norman ça vient d'eux northman l'homme
du nord ça désigne les vikings et donc
vous avez vous moquez de moi mais je
pense être une sorte de réincarnation de
deux vikings normal vous venez du nord
certes mais du nord pas de calais donc
pas tellement viking 1 éventuellement
tuning mais je sais mais c'est plus fort
que moi
toutes les nuits je suis le même rêve
sur cette plage où je me retrouve comme
un viking mais perdu désespéré fragile
et un temps je me sens observé est
traqué par un autre moi une sorte de
deux chefs du plan
[Musique]
bah
dragon des mers c'est le nom du vaisseau
ton brugge riez prêt à mener l'assaut or
d'animal de scandinavie les dieux ont
décidé de se rénover hui des terres des
monastères brise eu le faire terrorisé
coloniser les peuples angleterre
ah ah ah ah
c'est les tambours de naa
simple pas rien devenu mena
à leur coeur ne connaît pas là
ah ah ah ah
y'a le couvre-feu j'avais pas vu leur tu
vas pas renoncer tu ne vas pas reculer
tu dois par n'en sais tu ne dois pas
reculer à aa
c'est le bruit du tonnerre de ta
tu en fais partie joindre au combat
gérer off
dans les yeux tous les deux et tous les
mains t'en fais pas si je me rends
compte agir
dans les yeux j'ai lavé
on se retrouvera
toi et moi pour la
on se retrouvera va
les noix pour la
perso j'ai pas trop envie de me taper
pas du vieux on dit qu'on fait tous l'ap
j'arrive même pas soulevé mon épée
et en plus je suis plus petit mambo
cleyet
les crédits à madonna d un coup feu en
forêt je suis allergique au pollen
ah ah ah
aïe aïe
mal orange suis intolérant
debout et et chantage sur l'ennemi et si
on règle et ce avec un chiffon n'y allez
pas toi tu n'es plus un enfant
mais je tourne le
ça
renoncer j'ai un pan de côté je dois te
bagarrer je voulais juste te faire
ah ah ah ah
c'est le bruit de ma vente euros
en fait si je me rends combat gérer
ovale
dans les cieux
pas si sûr
combat jéricho val
dans les yeux j'ai lavé
on se retrouvera
toi et moi pour la
gloire
on se retrouvera
m
l'espoir dans ce rêve en dehors du temps
je suis un guerrier du nord alors certes
pas ragnarok broc ni le plus vaillant de
mon clan je suis même un peu une merde
bon bah ça va là haut mais je
progresserai trois mois j'entrerai pas
tremblant dans le palais dodin mais la
tête haute et un jour le monde entier se
délectera des récits de mes exploits
t'en fais pas si je me rends compte à
gérer au valhalla
dans les yeux tous les dieux
pouvait pas si je me rends compte agir
et au valhalla dans les yeux j'ai là
[Applaudissements]
toi et moi pour la
on se retrouvera
toi et moi
ça fera 80 euros quoi eh bien on
s'arrête là pour aujourd'hui ça fera 80
euros non remboursés mais aux apparences
qu'à me dire j'ai pas moins conseillé me
donner un truc de psy ah non à la
semaine prochaine
la portela nickel le pays
en fait pas si je me rends combat gérer
au valhalla dans les yeux tous les dieux
et tous les miens t'en fais pas si je me
rends compte à gérer
dans les yeux j'ai la minute
on se retrouvera
toi et moi pour l'infini pour l'accord